歡迎收看理財達安秀的籌碼教學單元
歌有籌必報
我們在之前曾經幫大家介紹過一集
有關於可轉債可轉換公司債的
簡單的介紹
因為很多人對這個產品還是有點陌生
可是這個是全鎮小歌的專長
透過發行可轉債
事實上公司有很多很多的想法
好 到最後大家只要記得一件事就是
公司通常都不想還債
他想拿什麼呢
他想拿股票來還給你就好囉
好 這後面就有很多的玄機了
所以今天呢 製作了第二集的進階版
就是來教大家
當今天公司發行了可轉債
OK 要還債了
要用什麼抵債
不是用肉身償債啦
是用股票償債
那為什麼你要接受股票
因為股票漲很多了
現在換成他的股票
我也樂意喔
也就代表股票會有一波拉抬的行情
今天教你去找這種
發債後股價將要發動的公司
那也提醒了
這一集有開車
不喜歡開車的
會暈車的要滲入了
好小哥
因為我們太久沒開車了
很悶啊
真的是很悶
所以藉由
藉由做這個專題教學
來開車
來開一下
在電視上不好開啊
對啊 網路上對不對
對啊 要正經為座
我們今天是要更深入了
之前都淺淺的
今天更深入了
因為上次只是教大家
到底什麼是可轉債
而且上次是神預言
可轉債的價格如果跌到太低
這家公司可能要還不出錢了
我們上次講一個三個字母的公司
哪三個字母
BHQ
反正都出事了嘛
這個你要很小心喔
這個看起來就好像會點點點
價格跌到那麼低
代表連自由在線的人都覺得它不行了嘛
都覺得它應該還不出來
還不出來了啦
通常這個我們可轉債的價格啦
你只要看到50塊
就北風北了
對 落跑了啦 不要賭了啦
對 快不行了
那後面就出事了
好 上次只是在講一個可轉債發行的概念
然後但是中間其實有講了稍微
它跟股價之間的一個對比關係
然後很多人就說不過癮啦
就是要聽後面的啊
就是要聽股價怎麼做啊
所以今天小哥來幫我們講了
到底怎麼觀察一家公司發了可轉債
什麼時候要拉股價
那我們還是要重點複習一下
可轉債最重要的就是轉換價
因為可轉債它有一個公式
轉換張數等於100除以轉換價
所以各位轉換價越低
代表換的帳數越多
所以通常我們都會看轉換價
發行的時候有沒有比較低
有比較低的話 這家董發
董發就有可能有機會會拉抬
舉例來說 轉換價是20塊
因為可轉載一張是100塊
20塊你就可以換股票可以換5張
轉換價是50塊就可以換2張
因為可轉載的股價是固定的
100塊喔 發行股價固定的
好 那轉換後的市值呢
這個叫Parity
Parity我們就來算一下
假設轉換價是20
轉換加上數就是5
股價到30塊了
那這時候你的可轉債
你就可以把它換成股票啦
因為你換成股票
30乘以5
它就值150了 現賺50
對 你認的時候才100
我前一天我有去認安吉
安吉的可轉載
對 太陽能的
我去認的時候才100塊而已
我是去抽的
抽到了
有個經紀人說
小哥拜託 捧場一下
幫我抽個安吉
可是可轉載不是還蠻多人願意認的嗎
我跟你講那時候空頭
沒有人要
跟現真一樣
沒有人要抽 你知道嗎
我想說捧場OK啦
那我就寫個100.05
怎麼不叫我們一起去一下咧
彭長我也不曉得
因為有的 給他後面破發之類的
無擔保有的還會到90幾
你知道嗎 我抽100.05
純粹彭長說你隨便寫個價格
你有寫我就有業績了
你不一定要抽到喔
所以他叫我寫低一點
那我就寫100.05
想不到全部抽到
全部抽到
100.05全部抽到我還嚇了一跳
還好啦 因為無論如何
它有100塊的回收價
對啊 你說原價回收嗎
可以換幾張
我那時候抽到50張
150 我都可以換幾張
那可以換幾張喔 不大記得
因為它轉換價不大記得
只是為了捧場
對 只是為了捧場
後面它又漲上來了
好
那我看到這個腳股就到40
CB的轉換市值就會變200
所以轉換市值很簡單
就100X標的的成交價
再除以CB的轉換價
所以轉後市值是跟標的成交價成正比的
所以這個數字標的成交價越高
轉後市值就會越高
所以一般而言公司派他們就會想辦法讓股價變高
股價變高你換的意願就變大
我就換成股票嘛
對 你要等股票
你不用拿錢給我了
對 所以我們要知道公司的這些企圖那你就可以站在公司派的同一陣線他要拉 你就知道他什麼時候要拉他不拉了 你也知道他什麼時候不拉了
公司發殼轉在最終結果
第一個就還錢
大部分人都不想還錢
還錢幹嘛 我們也討厭他還錢
不要還 你把股價拉一拉
用肉身抵戰 小哥最喜歡這種
不好說
拉起來讓可轉債換成股票最好啦
對啊
信用差的公司發可轉債
因為信用差公司它要籌資不容易
今天講的一些股票
你可能聽都沒聽過
有啦 我剛剛一看就跟小哥說
這些有點...
有點冷門
冷門還比較好聽
這些信用差公司
大部分就是為了不還錢
發債不還錢 你就是得拉
對
那這種呢 特定的人會賺到錢
就是有可轉載的人賺到錢嘛
公司呢 籌到錢嘛
那吃虧的就小股東
就一般啦 因為你股價拉上去總要回來嘛
上下一場空跟你沒關係
對 沒錯
好 可是沒關係 小股東可以學這集
我看你拉 我也自己來賺一下
好 那以上講這些喔
很多人都覺得 小哥你有沒有口訣啊
口訣來一下
口訣來一下 口訣好 衝脫泡蓋送之類的
衝突泡開送
那是什麼
那可轉再拉抬五口訣
看起來好像怪怪的
對 都是姿勢
都知識
知識 不是知識
好 五口訣
拉罐吹爆煥
這個好像在某些場合非常好用
某些場合
烫傷不能這樣搞
你說的該不會是阿公店
你有去過你
我是沒有去打工過啦 我就不知道
我這種年紀當然不是去阿公店的啦
來看你
叔叔店
拉什麼
拉什麼啦
拉客人
灌什麼
灌酒啊
灌酒 灌茶也可以
那吹爆什麼
吹爆什麼
欸欸欸
吹捧他啊
阿公要吹捧 阿公要吹
阿公來唱歌的嘛 對不對
阿公需要你吹他
吹嘘 讓他吹嘘一下
吹捧他 阿公唱得好好聽
吹捧他
那抱什麼
抱與熱烈掌聲啊
阿公就很開心啊
阿公高興抱了
阿公就回家了嘛
就換下一個阿公了
下一位
我回來好了 不要再開了
可轉載拉抬五口訣
各位啊 你就記得剛剛的故事
剛剛故事你記得之後
你就記得這五個口訣了
拉罐吹爆煥
第一個就是拉 拉什麼呢
拉誰
揭曉
拉漲停
拉漲停啊
這麼好
可轉載呢 我跟各位講
可轉載通常發動前
對
發動前呢 它要昭告天下
讓大家共襄盛舉
讓債主知道
換股票的時候
你不要叫我平時
不要叫我還錢
我是會拉股票的
所以第一招拉漲停
是 宣示
拉漲停給你看
拉漲停之後
眾人的目光就進來了
客人就來了
就拉進來了
好 那第二呢
灌什麼
好 第二個我們揭曉
灌營收
真的是灌酒
灌酒 灌水
你之後你就會看到營收進來了
那營收進來了
很多人看到營收成長
有些投資公司他們就自動進來買
事實上這種營收都是套路
營收都可以調整的
可以調整的
這個發票下個月再開
不要太早開
因為我們要營收增加
所以灌營收也是很重要的套路
做基本面的人可能看得出端倪
突然怎麼營收長起來不正常嗎
正常 又發載
只看題材的人就 營收突然大增耶
好像很好 慣營收
小哥最喜歡的 吹
吹什麼 還真的是吹捧
吹捧他 一樣的 是真的
真的是吹捧他 你會看到標的
報紙就開始在報導了
電視上面也有了
也有一些老師會喊這張股票喔
那這種就吹捧
吹捧這張股票
第四個呢 爆什麼
終於爆了
就爆了大量
爆大量
阿公有爆大量
阿公爆大量
不錯 不錯
身體不錯
阿公爆大量是非常好的事情
不然會阻塞
這一集被黃標的話 小哥自己負責
從頭到尾我們到底講了什麼不該講的呢
第五個
下一位
換股票
解決你了 花那麼多力氣
終於把客人送走了
終於出來了
出來了要給錢
叫做換股票
他意思說我可以把股票
可轉載換成股票
股票就拿去賣掉
那就有錢了
做這麼多的事情
就為了讓他換股票
前面做這件事也要花錢的呢
幹嘛那麼累 為什麼不還錢啊
這問題問得很好
所以有些我們就要特別觀察一下假設他離轉換價很遠的例如說像廣定轉換價在三倍遠就是股價要漲到三倍
真的做不上
那這種你要不要拉罐吹爆換
算了 還錢好了
還就還 還錢比較快
當它的股價離轉換價很近的
努力一下看看
因為拉有可能你花個50萬來拉
不要講50萬 太少
花個5000萬來拉
但是你借了3億
划算
所以大部分的公司還是喜歡拉
好 一定是有一點槓桿的
花小錢 國大錢 對
那有些是自然而然漲上去的
我們也不能說每一家股票
都是刻意拉上去的
我們不能說發債的公司都那麼壞
不行
其實很多發債公司
我拿到錢我正當的做好我的本業
結果他就上去了
對 沒錯
因為他發債 發完債他建設他的公司
然後營收也自動進來了
對
那個營收是自然灌進來的
還不是人為灌進來的
我們是無罪推定
你沒有證據不能這樣
所以我們在講下面的公司
都是好公司
到底誰呢
我們要抓住剛才那個五口訣
什麼時候拉
什麼時候爆
沒錯 五口訣
來看第一個
目前可轉載最貴的一檔
我記得你在達人秀講過
對 8097長城最貴一檔
它在去年6月21號發債
那發完債之後有三個月是不能換的
所以那時候也不用幹嘛
也不用幹嘛
然後在去年11月4號
漲停第一根
你不要看到漲停第一根
有隔湊去空它
來 拉囉拉囉
不要喔
有可轉債的漲停第一根
通常都是宣示的
是
各位記得喔
它漲停第一根的時候
籌碼可能沒有很漂亮
那這種低檔籌碼沒有很漂亮的
不能空
因為這種空它很危險喔
畢竟在低檔
對 這種有可能一個大波段喔
好 拉漲停
然後呢 後面怎麼樣
後面各位看一下
這營收就怎麼樣
歪歪歪往上跑
營收就上來了嘛
營收就自然而然的灌進來了
那後面呢
這個換股票我們會從哪邊看得出來呢
會從融券現場看得出來
因為當股價往上漲的時候
有的人會先去放空鎖單
然後再把可轉債換成股票
做這個融券現場這個動作
避免之後股價掉下來對不對
對 很聰明
所以這個融券現場動作
各位 你看到融券現場動作
就是代表有人在換了
不過那也要有券可以空
真的 對
有的股票 有的可轉債是沒有資券的
對啊 沒有資券 或剛好遇到要回補券的時候
沒有資券 我教你一招
你可以先把一些可轉債換成股票
然後一邊賣股票 一邊買便宜的可轉債
因為那時候通常可以套利
賣股票 買可轉債 再把可轉債換股票
做這個流程
感覺上有第三集可以做
我們先把剛剛那個五步驟講完
所以你看 拉 灌 換
那爆大量 爆了沒
最近爆了大量了
之前都是低檔
最近都是大量
然後只剩一個吹
吹叫做什麼 吹捧它
吹不是應該在爆之前嗎
沒有吹怎麼爆
沒有錯
所以我們來看 這邊吹捧的日期
就在爆大量之前
有可能一吹就爆了
沒動頭嘛
有的要吹很久
要吹久
吹捧它之後這個量就出來了
所以各位看一下
利多新聞不斷
長城訂單看到明年Q1
這個就利多
還有這個
長城的受惠墨西哥電信商大單貢獻
五月營收大增25倍
哇塞
嚇死人
這個營收大增很多
還有這長城電單能見住見到明年Q1
下半年渴望新增拉美電信商的客戶
這邊有一堆營收
就是叫做吹
吹了之後後面補價就噴了
好
這是第一檔
好 但是噴完了換下一位
下一位 大總控來了
換
下一位 大總控3701
大總控是在去年的9月10號發債
然後發債前要定價
發債前大概是半個月定價
然後半個月定價完了之後
這個是迫不及待
這個很急 很猴急
他在發債前9月1號就漲停了
很頭急 立馬翹起來
然後走了一個大大的波段
所以各位 你看到有發債 有漲停
很有可能就是一個大波段的開始喔各位後面你看看當股價漲上來的時候它的營收也是漲上來的是在高檔呢
你也發現高檔有怎麼樣
大量的券線長換出
好
所以各位看一下
拉
對
然後呢怎麼樣
這個有吹捧
好
你在等我回答
換股票
拉有罐有吹有爆
拉罐吹爆
好
一樣有利多也是有這個吹的部分
利多很多
大眾控去年1、2、1
一直在講他元宇宙元宇宙
對嘛他到底是不是元宇宙
車用元宇宙題材爆發
車用加元宇宙厲害
厲害兩個都有
兩個都有到底有沒有
難怪噴這麼多
股價連兩天漲停
大眾公三 事業貢獻轉強
AR HDUG
一堆利多
明年底出貨你現在就在吹
吹到明年底
吹到明年底嘴巴很痠
好 這個利多新聞太多了
後面呢
後面也跌下來了
所以這個股票都這樣
好 來
再我們來看下一檔
它算是有基本面
有基本面
所以我們說這幾檔
講的好像前兩檔沒有一樣
但這檔是有
它的營收有的是人為灌的
有的是自然的就灌進來了
好 那這一樣
它在4、5月的時候發債
10月21號拉漲停
拉漲停完之後
因為你看這月營收後面也上來了
拉漲停 灌營收
那後面也有利多
最近在高檔它也出了量
可轉載也大幅的轉換
在這裡大幅轉換
這很多人會問
那這種大幅轉換
你要去放空嗎
我沒有叫你放空
我們只是跟你說
當漲很多大幅轉換
萬一主力呈現賣超的時候
這邊還主力還沒有呈現賣超
假如主力呈現賣超的時候
就是你下車的好時機
我覺得不一定要空的原因是
大家去查一下過去基本面穩不穩定
沒錯 如果相對是獲利營收相對穩定
像剛剛看它那個線不是這樣的
它其實是有點高原的
這種的其實就不要亂空
它可能真的就是一個很穩定在獲利的公司
對 好 那我們看
它後面有一些利多新聞
連接器廠參觀還有全新Q市營收獲利維持雙年增
這些不錯的新聞股價就已經來到高點了
所以你要在低檔的時候拉漲停的時候
你就要準備進場了
因為這種拉漲停通常都是一個宣示
接下來我們看
6217的中碳增
這個其實也算是有營收獲利體質的公司
你是有體財的喔
不是那種爛公司啦
所以我們說這家公司也是懂發啦
因為他知道後面的營收還不錯
可能自己先知道的
低檔的發債
2021年8月27日發債
9月3日漲停
然後呢
很快就宣示了耶
很快宣示喔
好 那這主力的籌碼其實支起來不錯
但最近的籌碼看起來比較差
就變差了
最近籌碼看起來比較差
好 那營收其實這邊也有成長
你看之前還有到63%
高檔也有呈現大幅的轉換
然後它也有一些
利多消息
利多的新聞
各位看一下
而且說實話蠻多投顧之前在推它
蠻多推的
好 利多新聞不斷
所以我們說
我們不是說至少這種公司不好
就是說當低檔
你看到漲停有發可轉載的時候
你記得準備進場
等到以後利多新聞出來的時候
這時候你再想你到底要不要賣股票
因為常常都是漲了一個大的波段
好 所以小哥的五字訣學起來了沒
要先拉然後再灌然後再吹
然後就爆然後你就換下一檔
好但是這個流程呢
剛舉的例子是已經都走到快完了
所以呢在我們的榮耀班
請你務必訂閱起來
因為小哥會來告訴你
即將要走這一套流程
他在關注的名單有哪些
這個很重要喔
我們來看看一起陪他們經過這五個步驟的轉換好不好
今天非常謝謝小哥幫我們再更進階的解釋了
可轉再跟股價之間的關係
其實大家只要記得一件事啦
公司當然是缺一些現金嘛
才會發債
但發債之後公司的發展就不一定了
到最後要還錢
有的人可能有錢嘛 就還
但很多人是希望
沒關係 我拉股價比較快
我拉股價還你 你也開心
我也開心 大家都開心
只有原本的小股東可能不太開心而已喔
所以理解公司的念頭
了解他們會如何進行拉抬股價的五步驟
事實上我們不但可以認可轉戰
我們更可以賺到股價喔
那希望今天的歌有仇必報
帶給你不同心的財經知識囉
我們下次再見了 掰掰